Oh what happened there I don't know I
held that for a long time okay for
example duck dynasty I was watching duck
dynasty we all watch duck dynasty there
it is yeah and then I hit the info
button and it said helpless dumb animals
try to catch some ducks yeah then I
watched the show Alaska State Troopers
yeah and that was curious so I hit the
info button and it said this week
something almost happened watching The
Voice I was watching The Voice that's a
part for the show yep and then I hit the
info button it said the most successful
ad ever run by the American swivel-chair
Association 60 minutes I was watching 60
minutes hit the info button and it said
tune in to watch the triumphant
synthesis of taxidermy and animatronics
oh that's not fair oh yeah watch this
The Cosby Show I was watching The Cosby
Show hit the info button it said no
comment
[Applause]
don't drink that all right
[Applause]
you have a problem with that you talked
to me after the show I'll be in the
parking lot 19 Kids and Counting that's
a show yeah and then it says here you
hit the info button
America's reminder to wear a condom
and finally I watched my show Conan and
it said another reminder
[Applause]
[Music]
why you really love that one
we wish you had never been born
[Laughter]
you